(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula nós vamos falar sobre os leilões
de fração ideal e leilão de parte ideal.
São sinônimos, vamos entender o que isso significa.
Nesse tipo de leilão não está sendo leiloado
a totalidade do imóvel, e sim uma fração
desse imóvel.
Por que que isso acontece?
Existem dois casos.
Primeiro caso, pessoa é condenada pelo Poder Judiciário
e não tem a integralidade de um imóvel,
somente parte desse imóvel.
Uma forma de pagar essa dívida é leiloar
essa parte do imóvel.
Então vamos aqui a um exemplo hipotético.
Eu sou proprietária de um apartamento com umas
três pessoas.
Cada um tem 25% de um apartamento.
Vamos supor que esse apartamento vale 400 mil
reais, então cada um tem direito a 100
mil reais do que vale aquele apartamento.
É inegável que isso é um valor expressivo
que eu tenho de propriedade.
Vamos supor que eu fui condenada pelo Poder
Judiciário e eu não tenho outros bens.
O único bem que eu tenho é esse
bem imóvel, 25% de um apartamento.
Então a forma de eu pagar aquela dívida
que foi condenada judicialmente é leiloar essa parte
que eu tenho daquele apartamento.
Então poderia acontecer um leilão somente de 25
% da parte que eu tenho aquele apartamento.
Segundo caso, o devedor ele até tem a
integralidade do imóvel, mas o valor da dívida
é inferior ao valor do imóvel e o
imóvel admite divisão.
Nesse caso, o juiz determina que somente uma
fração desse imóvel seja leiloado, pois já seria
suficiente para quitar a dívida.
Vamos também a um exemplo hipotético.
Eu tenho um terreno e esse terreno é
bem grande e tem um valor de um
milhão de reais.
Eu fui condenada judicialmente a pagar uma dívida
de 50 mil reais, por exemplo, e o
único bem que eu tenho é esse meu
terreno de um milhão.
Não seria razoável que a totalidade do meu
terreno fosse a leilão para pagar uma dívida
de 50 mil reais.
Afinal de contas, o meu terreno vale um
milhão e o meu terreno é um bem
divisível.
É possível que somente uma parcela desse meu
terreno vá a leilão e somente essa parcela
seja suficiente para quitar aquilo que eu estou
devendo e fui condenada judicialmente.
Então pode ser que o juiz determine, por
exemplo, que somente 20% do meu terreno
vá a leilão, porque isso já seria mais
do que o suficiente para quitar aquela dívida
que eu fui condenada.
Qual é a consequência de você participar de
um leilão de fração ideal ou de parte
ideal?
Se o imóvel for indivisível, o arrematante será
proprietário em conjunto com outras pessoas.
Isso aqui é muito negativo.
Por quê?
Vamos voltar àquele exemplo em que eu tenho
25% de um apartamento.
Então somente a minha parte do apartamento foi
a leilão.
Vamos supor que você arrematou os 25%
que eu tinha daquele apartamento.
Você ficará no meu lugar.
Você será proprietário de 25% e será
proprietário da totalidade daquele apartamento em conjunto com
outros três proprietários.
Mas perceba, você participou desse leilão e você
não tem a menor ideia de quem são
esses outros três proprietários.
Isso aí é muito ruim.
Por quê?
Porque você teria que entrar em um consenso
com essas três pessoas que você nunca viu
na vida para alugar aquele imóvel, para vender
aquele imóvel.
E esse consenso, não preciso nem explicar porquê,
ele é muito difícil.
Afinal de contas, pessoas casadas há anos não
conseguem entrar em consenso quando envolve um bem
imóvel.
Imagine você com aquelas pessoas que você nunca
viu na vida.
Então o que aconteceria?
Você tentaria, em primeiro lugar, vender sua parte
para algum desses outros três proprietários.
Se nenhum deles quisesse comprar e não existisse
um consenso entre vocês para a venda daquele
imóvel, a totalidade da venda daquele imóvel, você
teria que recorrer ao poder judiciário para que
o judiciário determinasse a venda daquele imóvel.
Pode ser que mesmo o final de processo
em que todos os proprietários sejam condenados a
vender aquele imóvel, porque afinal de contas, uma
pessoa não é obrigada a ficar com o
bem que ela não quer mais, então o
judiciário, a partir do momento que existe um
que não quer mais ficar, determinaria a venda
daquele bem.
Ocorrendo essa determinação da venda, se ainda assim,
algum dos outros proprietários batesse o pé e
falasse que não iria vender, o que aconteceria
com esse imóvel?
Esse imóvel iria acabar em um leilão, então
o imóvel entraria em um leilão de novo.
É bem comum achar imóvel em leilão exatamente
desse caso, não de caso que alguém comprou
uma fração ideal, porque geralmente as pessoas já
nem participam desse leilão, porque entendem que é
furada, mas no caso, por exemplo, de que
dois irmãos são donos de um apartamento, um
quer vender, o outro não quer, então o
que quer vender?
Entra na justiça, a justiça determina que ocorra
a venda, eles não entram em um consenso
para a venda de forma tradicional e aquele
imóvel acaba em leilão.
Então não participe de um leilão de fração
ideal, de um bem indivisível, a não ser
que você assuma o risco de ser proprietário
com gente que você nunca conheceu na vida.
Apartamentos e casas são indivisíveis, não comportam divisão.
Agora, e se o imóvel for divisível?
Se o imóvel for divisível, pode acontecer o
desmembramento e o arrematante será responsável por esses
custos.
Vamos voltar ao meu segundo exemplo em que
eu sou proprietária de um terreno.
Então esse meu terreno era muito grande, com
um valor de mercado muito alto e o
juiz determinou que somente um percentual dele fosse
a leilão, você arrematou esse percentual.
Como ele é um terreno e ele é
um bem indivisível, você poderia realizar a divisão
desse terreno, mas você como arrematante vai ser
o responsável por pagar as custas desse desmembramento.
Isso aí tem custas que envolvem um cartão
de registro de imóveis e o arrematante teria
que pagar.
Agora, fique bem atento a uma situação.
Um bem, ele até pode ser divisível, mas
pode ser que a prefeitura do município onde
está localizado aquele bem, ela tenha determinado uma
regra em seu plano municipal em que não
vai admitir terrenos muito pequenos.
Então é comum que as prefeituras determinem que
um terreno ele tem que ter no mínimo
uma metragem de frente e uma metragem de
lateral.
Então pode ser que aquele terreno que você
arrematou nem mesmo seja possível o desmembramento por
descumprir as regras da prefeitura, porque em regra
um terreno é um imóvel divisível, mas como
vai descumprir a regra da prefeitura, pode ser
que você não consiga desmembrar esse terreno.
Fique muito atento a esses casos, recorra às
normas específicas do município onde está localizado o
imóvel que você quer arrematar somente uma fração
dele e fique atento se seria possível ou
não você desmembrar um terreno se fosse o
caso de uma fração ideal de um terreno.
E saiba que mesmo se for divisível, você
vai ter que pagar as custas para desmembrar
esse imóvel.
Lembre que casas e apartamentos são bens em
regra indivisíveis, então se você participar de um
leilão de uma fração ideal de uma casa
ou de um apartamento, você será proprietário em
conjunto com outras pessoas que você nunca viu
na vida.
Leilão de fração ideal, de parte ideal, é
em 90% dos casos furada.
Fique muito atento.
O edital vai falar especificamente se aquele leilão
somente tem a fração ideal dele.
Ele vai colocar lá um terço do imóvel,
25% do imóvel, 17% do imóvel,
sempre vai constar no edital, basta que você
leia o edital para saber se a integralidade
do imóvel que está indo a leilão ou
se é somente uma parte daquele imóvel.
Atenção, não confunda leilão de fração ideal, de
parte ideal, com fração ideal que um imóvel
localizado dentro de um condomínio possui.
O que é isso?
Eu já falei aqui antes no curso que,
por exemplo, um apartamento localizado dentro de um
condomínio, ele tem sua área privativa e ele
tem a sua área comum.
O que é essa área comum?
É uma parte do terreno onde aquele condomínio
está localizado que cada apartamento faz jus.
Então vamos colocar aqui um exemplo.
Um apartamento tem uma área privativa de 80
metros, uma área comum de 50 metros e
depois ele vai ter uma área total de
130 metros.
Essa área privativa de 80 metros é o
que efetivamente aquele apartamento possui de área interna.
Essa área comum diz respeito à parcela daquele
terreno que esse imóvel tem direito.
Nesse nosso caso hipotético aqui, 50 metros.
E pode ser que a própria matrícula do
imóvel coloque lá que esses 50 metros correspondem
a 0,01% do terreno daquele condomínio.
E tudo bem, isso aí não é uma
fração do terreno daquele condomínio.
Esse apartamento ele pode ser levado na integralidade,
mas ele vai ter lá essa observação de
fração ideal.
O que você precisa ficar muito atento é
em leilão de fração ideal.
Um leilão é que somente uma parcela do
imóvel vai a leilão e não a sua
totalidade.
Você precisa saber que qualquer imóvel que está
localizado dentro de um condomínio vai ter a
fração ideal daquele terreno.
Isso aí, tudo bem, você pode participar normalmente.
São duas coisas com o mesmo nome, com
sentidos diferentes.
Fique atento somente ao leilão de parte ideal,
fração ideal.
Quando você pegar um apartamento ou uma casa
dentro de um condomínio e tiver lá uma
expressão sobre a parte ideal daquele terreno que
faz jus àquele apartamento e que é aquela
casa, tudo bem, siga em frente desde que
esteja sendo leiloada a totalidade daquele imóvel.
Fique atento que são coisas com nomes iguais
com sentidos completamente diferentes.
Você deve ficar atento ao leilão de parte
ideal e fração ideal.